assalamualaikum greetings apiece now
there's a new netflix film that has
really offended christians and it should
offend us also and i'm gonna cover three
points as to why so number one is that
if you didn't know as a christian or
just in general basic knowledge that
Jesus is a prophet in Islam he's one of
the greatest messengers I was ever sent
at his time now we don't worship Him as
a god or son of God we believe that he
was sent to call people to worship God
just like Moses Abraham and the last and
final message no problem I'm a peace and
blessings be upon him so these are
Jesus's honored in Islam to utter one
bad thing against him to deny him to
slander him to lie against him this can
buy you a one-way ticket now buy you get
you a free one-way took it to the
Hellfire so there's also a whole chapter
named after his Blessed Mother in the
Koran which many Christian don't know
about so he holds such a high level in
Islam Islam simply means to submit your
will to God like in the Lord's player or
our Father who art in heaven hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come Thy will be
done this means Islam to do God's will
to submit your will to God's will this
is what Islam simply means in a Muslim
is one who does Islam a submitter to
God's will a peacefully submitting your
will to God so now knowing that Jesus
peace be upon him is one of the greatest
messengers in Islam and to dishonor him
in any way this is something that can
land someone in the Hellfire so to say
any derogatory thing about him just like
what they're doing in this Netflix film
painting him out to be someone that he's
not lying on him slandering him painting
it to him out to the immoral etc this
offends us the same way it would offend
us if when when they do dishonor the
last and final messenger said the
mankind problem Hamid peace and
blessings be upon him
this also angers us upsets saddens us
number two is many Christians point out
look when they know what happens look
how the Muslim world gets in an uproar
when they offend Prophet Muhammad peace
is blessing to be upon him and Jesus now
what are you guys doing I mean there's
close to 2 billion Muslims those who
submit their will to to the one God in
the world so what are we doing now I
mean we need to let our voices be heard
I mean that's a discussion with our
Christian brothers this is humanity for
another time we give them doubt we
called them to the pure monotheism to
call them to Jesus true message of only
worshiping the crater not the creation
you know explaining to him that Jesus
never called people to worship himself
he called people to worship the Creator
the one God another discussion no
problem but now we need to stand
together these satanic dark forces are
pushing hard and the last final message
I sent to mankind Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him said what what
he saying he said if you see an evil
here at evil what do you do what do you
do you tried to change it with your
hands you speak out against it or hate
it in your heart we need to speak out
against it we need to stand in
solidarity with look we all have the
same father Adam we're all brothers and
sisters in humanity and this as it
outrages it angers it saddens it offends
Christians we need to now show the same
way when it offends Prophet Muhammad
when they do something offends us it
also offends us when you offend Jesus
you offend Muslims no doubt about it
number three action items what are we
gonna do now go ahead there's I've been
over 1 million I believe signatures in
Brazil this is what that film is made
and now the Netflix is starting to push
it out Fox even Network push it out this
supposed to be a conservative like also
Christian you know people should also
think the Christians look look what your
Fox is doing to you many of these these
are some of these extremists radicals
think think think you know and they try
to divide Christians and Muslims have us
fighting each other and whatnot look you
have your belief we have ours Wayne
going nowhere you're not going there we
need to work together this is a great
example of us now coming to work
together to try to push back against
these evil satanic forces who are not
only offending you as Christians
we also have a claim to Jesus peace be
upon him as he's mentioned more times in
the Quran than Prophet Muhammad is even
a chapter named after his Blessed Mother
and I've discussed in point number one
so the action night is I believe that
every Muslim leader now this is great
opportunity to let the world know great
opportunity for Dawa to let put a
statement out to tweet something post
something and let it be known that we
also when you offend Jesus ISA lease and
our peace be upon him you also offend
Muslims because Muslims we love Jesus
you cannot be a Muslim one who has
submitted his or her will to the Creator
to the One God unless you believe it's
an article of faith to believe in and
love Jesus so again the same way
Christians are offended let all Muslims
let the world know that we also when you
offend Jesus when you offend Moses when
you a friend Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessing be upon them all they were all
brothers in faith they all brought Islam
they all call people to submit they
called humanity to submit their will to
God that's what Islam is so when you
offend any of these honored men these
great men these messengers you offend us
too you offend us too so let's stand
with our brothers in humanity and let
our voices be heard I said I want a comb
and the greetings of Jesus and the
greetings of the last to final measure
problem Hamid peace and blessings be
upon him Moses and all these message
that they all wished peace to the world
calling people to the purpose of life
and we wish nothing but the best for all
of mankind peace be with you
assalamualaikum